dinger and Rother feels as much for
coming of age story for you as an
actress as it is for your character in
the film feels like it's your first
adult performance in a way yeah it's
definitely after reading the script I
had a huge connection to it just because
of all the emotions that I would sort of
get to portray if I you know got the
opportunity to actually play ginger and
I thought that that would be so exciting
and you know a challenge you know to
also do the accent and something new and
I was I was very excited about that
tell me about the accent is well L
because obviously you do a British
accent in this and you're not frigid as
we could tell and also Dakota your
sisters in an English accent recently
hasn't she so was it liked in the accent
and did you give each other any tips
well the act I worked I remember I was
so nervous because I had to you know I
auditioned in front of Sally and she's
obviously she's from London and I never
done accent before so I was so nervous
but um it I worked with the dialogue
dialect coach and and from that we try
to perfect it so I wouldn't be you know
when we started filming that was just
already there so I wouldn't be thinking
about that because the audience can
definitely tell that you're gonna
thinking about that one word if you how
was it did you give each of the tips as
well you indicated Sashi we did our
accents were different because mine was
in the sixties and hers was more modern
so we didn't really we couldn't really
give any to each other tips but hers was
I thought was impeccable she did such a
good job
did you know much about that 60s period
before you came to make the film I did a
little bit but I also I Sally grew up in
that time so from that I sort of picked
her brain about what it was like and
sort of growing up in the time of how so
scary where the there might not be a
tomorrow
you